bien alors qu'arles votre vrai nom c'est
marc tellenne ouais hein vous le savez
ça mais
tu te rappelles tu reviens
parc c'est marc tellenne que je voudrais
recevoir maintenant sur ce plateau on va
faire l'interview marc tellenne
[Musique]
marc tn bonsoir c'est la première fois
que vous vous retrouvez sur un plateau
de télévision ah ouais ça fait drôle ça
fait drôle un peu les boules a pu avec
des grands artistes comme ça que je vois
la télévision savez j'ai tout vocation
celle ci talent et si ce
film j'ai été voir votre pièce bien
marquer la
marque que vous êtes né le 6 août 1961 à
aix-les-bains exactement comme karl zéro
vous l'avez rencontré quand ce type
c'est mon jumeau c'est un jumeau
stellaire belges et les rencontres et
j'ai même été sosie officiel sous le nom
de marc tellenne de cartes 0 j'ai ma
carte du sosie club international et ils
sont non karl zéro salut est venu
comment ça c'était en 77 un jour vasile
de coqs mon frère rentrer à la maison et
dia une nouvelle mode c'est la mode punk
il faut se taillader les cheveux ouais à
l'époque j'en avais sur le réussit à
l'époque j'en avais une médaille à lui
immédiatement et je suis devenu punk
aussi sec et vous êtes appelés karl zéro
et women ils font un nom punk j'ai dit
car 0 vous êtes jaloux de 4,0 marque
non non non j'aimerais pas avoir sa vie
ouais non il paraît qu'il a dit son
maire de man souvent en retard il ya des
menaces et tout mais les courageux en
même temps il est quoi je l'admiré
beaucoup j'aurais aimé être comme lui
j'avais ainsi gluant à six points car ça
non je serai pas être aussi modeste
d'autre part laissé tomber il m'a pas
laissé tomber il pense à moi ouais il
m'a présenté une femme charmante avec
qui nous avons eu des enfants donc il
m'a franchement vous pensez quoi de la
carrière de karl zéro marque j'aurais
jamais pensé qu'il fera une carrière
ouais bah ouais ben journée ils étaient
jeunes qu'il n'y avait aucune raison
quoi c'est un vrai journaliste karl zéro
ou pas oui c'est certainement un vrai
jean ministre mais il n'a pas de carte
aïe la note car elle n'appartient
théâtre car il a une carte tu peux
revenir quand tu veux une marque c'est
vrai qu'il a un peu le melon karl zéro
il l'a eu il a eu vachement avec la
fesse en fait ouais en 81
7 on a été engagé par francis bouygues
etienne mougeotte patrick le lay qui
nous ont convoqués qui venait d'acheter
la chaîne ils nous ont dit on a besoin
de vedettes des jeunes et on a dit oui
nous sommes d'immenses stars des jeunes
ils ont dit combien voulait être payé et
on s'est regardé et que j'arrive on a
dit [ __ ] il faut demander un truc
énorme et le plus énorme qu'on pouvait
imaginer c'était 40 mille francs mais
rennes où c'était ils ont dit oui et là
on a eu le melon mais vraiment grave
pendant un mois quand on a fait une
émission c'était une insulte pirates et
aux pirates et on a été lourd des
marques très pas qu'il en fait un peu
trop karl zéro ça dépend des moments
suivi au moment où est pas tout le temps
il ya un truc qui est terrible chez carl
c qui perd ses cheveux et vous marque
vous les perdez non mais moi j'ai eu
recours aux implants donc contrairement
à 4,0 j'arrive à être fois c'est la
donne est changée chez toi ça se voit à
paris chez karl plus haut point il sait
vous coucher avec sa femme je lui ai pas
dit non parce que moi je chéris faire
lui il est fatigué stressé et au soir il
est crevé bien sûr
aujourd'hui arrive la vraie course est
grave et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux